[Musica]
al mondo è già stato inventato tutto
quindi uscite di casa
sedetevi a un angolo di strada e
sforzatevi di vedere le cose che gli
altri non vedono
era il 2012 studiavo economia e questa
frase la disse il professore di
strategia e management
alla fine di un suo corso
da quando l'ho sentita questa frase
ho sempre cercato di guardare le cose
con un'altra prospettiva
da un'angolazione diversa con un occhio
diverso
sforzandomi di vederle quelle cose che
gli altri non vedevano
per esempio che cosa vedete qui
un peperone cioè un peperone essiccato
vi hanno dato delle shopper prima e
all'interno
dovreste avere una bustina vi chiedo di
prenderla e tenetela lì non la aprite se
l'avete già fatto
questo peperone e quella bustina sono
ciò che si vede
ma che cosa non si vede o meglio che
cosa ci ho visto io io ci ho provato a
vedere in questo peperone
un possibile futuro
nel 2017
ci ho visto un possibile futuro e per
vedere questo futuro dobbiamo andare un
attimo nel passato un economista
george akerlof nel 1970 elaborano la
teoria che si chiama theory of le mans è
alla base di una teoria più complessa
con cui ha vinto il nobel nel 2000 e nel
è molto complessa la teoria quindi la
riducono all'osso
questa teoria parte dall'assunto di una
della cosiddetta selezione avversa
akerlof cerca di spiegare i fallimenti
del mercato libero e dice che questi
mercati falliscono per il principio
della selezione avversa
se ci sono delle condizioni
prevalentemente di prezzo ed
informazione per cui
beni di qualità superiore nel mercato
non trovano mai collocazione e quindi
per essere scambiati devono uscire da
quel mercato per trovarne uno più adatto
a loro
che cosa succede che scambio dopo
scambio la qualità del mercato si
abbassa perché i beni scambiati saranno
di qualità sempre inferiore e quindi il
mercato si muove con una selezione che è
avversa cioè contraria alla qualità
ma stavamo cercando le cose che gli
altri non vedevano che cosa c'entra
questa cosa proviamo a fare un esercizio
di pratica
io vengo da un paesino che si chiama
teggiano sud sud italia entroterra una
delle aree interne della campania 8 mila
abitanti ho fatto il liceo nella mia
terza liceo eravamo classico eravamo 24
persone 24 studenti che all'università
vanno tutti fuori tutti fuori sede
mediamente tutti quanti i rom a milano
comunque fuori ora immaginate
24 persone e 24 famiglie che supportano
gli studi di 24 giovani fuori dal
territorio fuori sede
producendo un reddito atteggiano e
trasferendo questo reddito in un'altra
zona pagando libri affitti
non lo so farmaci la retta universitaria
il cibo non lo dico perché sappiamo che
c'è il pacco da giu quindi non lo dico
però lo fanno in un territorio che è
diverso da quello di origine
e lo fanno per cinque anni qual è il
risultato alla fine di questi cinque
anni
il risultato alla fine di questi cinque
anni cioè quello che si vede è questo
supporto che danno i genitori e le
famiglie
ok e lo fanno per avere un reddito
maggiore per i loro figli una formazione
maggiore un reddito maggiore posizioni
di lavoro migliori ok
quello che si vede è questo quello che
non si vede che questo reddito che ha
alimentato la formazione perché questi
studenti siano migliori e siano persone
migliori domani al sud non tornerà più
e non tornerà più perché nei luoghi dove
questi studenti ormai formati e laureati
questi luoghi si sono in questi luoghi
si sono formati che cosa è successo che
alla fine di questi cinque anni questi
specializzati avranno trovato lì delle
condizioni che sono migliori magari
altri che si sono laureati come loro
avranno trovato non dico l'amore della
loro vita ma altre persone che
condividono il loro su strato culturale
o avranno trovato nelle condizioni di
vita e di lavoro migliori della loro
zona di origine e l'avranno trovata lì
perché ci saranno stati maggiori
investimenti da parte delle imprese
delle delle amministrazioni delle
istituzioni che li avranno fatti lì
perché lì ci sono state le condizioni di
mercato migliori per poterle fare quindi
l'utenza la potenziale forza lavoro
altre infrastrutture quindi che cosa
succede legge di akerlof selezione
avversa che cosa abbiamo detto scambio
dopo scambio
i beni di qualità migliore non vengono
non si scambia sul mercato ed escono dal
mercato
anno dopo anno gli studenti meridionali
restano fuori quindi escono dopo il
mercato forse la sto facendo troppo
facile ma se quelle 24 persone quei 24
studenti della mia classe di liceo
rappresentano un campione significativo
allora il campione è valido per
l'ottanta per cento perché di quelle 24
persone siamo tornati al sud solo in
quattro solo in quattro e questo
processo sia l'uno quello di migrazione
di e di
sviluppo delle zone dove confluiscono
questi studenti e di invece di
peggioramento delle condizioni funziona
a spirale positiva o negativa e ogni
anno questa spirale si si si allarga ok
questa questa forbice si allarga
il risultato per il meridione d'italia
qual è perché pensateci bene io vi ho
fatto un esempio su una classe di un
anno di un liceo di una zona interna
della campania ma immaginate
15 anni io mi sono diplomato nel 2007
immaginate per 15 anni riportate questo
discorso a tutte le scuole di tutte di
tutto il meridione d'italia in cui sono
andati gli studenti a studiare fuori e
non sono più tornati l'ottanta per cento
di quelli gli studenti mediamente non è
più tornata risultato meno persone più
specializzate che tornano qualità del
reddito diminuita quantità del reddito
diminuita spopolamento se vi andate a
guardare i dati stato i dati svimez vi
accorgerete che non è esagerato quello
che vi sto dicendo
c'era una soluzione
probabilmente sì
questa era la slide che vi volevo far
vedere
c'era una soluzione a questo processo
probabilmente sì bisognava vedere le
cose che gli altri non vedevano che
stiamo cercando
ma per vedere le cose che gli altri non
vedono bisogna fare a volte ai
ragionamenti che gli altri non fanno
e questa cosa fa sentire un po alienati
perché ci si ci si confronta con la
propria visione il tentativo di una
visione di cose che non ci sono o non ci
sono ancora è una realtà che è di fronte
a noi che tutti vedono e che comunemente
accettata da tutti perché pensateci bene
dopo il covip con lo smalto working è un
po accettabile adesso l'idea di tornare
al sud c'è qualcuno che è tornato per un
periodo qualcun altro che è ritornato al
sud cioè sta adesso di nuovo al sud sono
nate anche delle start up per fare
lavori da città in campagna
benissimo bellissimo ma credetemi nel
2017 quando io ho detto ai miei amici io
facevo parte di quell 80 per cento che
non sarebbe più tornato
ho detto ai miei amici ragazzi mollo e
il lavoro vado in campania aprono
azienda agricola coltivo i peperoni 8 su
10 mi hanno guardato come un folle cioè
un pazzo totale 8 su 10 uno mi ha
aiutato gli voglio un bene
assurdo ciao antonio se mi sta guardando
e il decimo ero io il decimo ero io e il
problema è che la realtà che mi con con
qui mi confrontavo cioè ero preso come
folle perché la realtà con cui mi
confrontavo era la solita realtà che il
meridionale il laureato meridionale al
sud non può tornare perché al sud che ci
viene a fare non c'è niente sprechi una
laurea tornaci per le vacanze e feste
comandate viene a trovare i parenti e
poi peggio ancora se volevi fare un
progetto in agricoltura ancora peggio
perché c'è sempre quel retaggio della di
quella storia bucolica quel piccolo
mondo antico in cui non è possibile fare
innovazione in agricoltura
al sud italia o mio dio
e poi c'era un'altra visione quella
proprio dell'agricoltura che è duale
pensateci bene
noi viviamo una visione dell'agricoltura
ancora oggi che è fatta di due estremi
il primo estremo e quello del contadino
piccolo contadino con il piccolo pezzo
di terra con la zappa a mano magari
sgrammaticato che non sa parlare
l'italiano ma è genuino quanto sono
buone queste verdure che fa
e poi un'altra visione quella magari
della grande industria sottomessa alle
logiche del mercato
non lo so delle serre con sfruttano che
sfruttano il lavoro e che è brutta
sporca e cattiva ma questa visione così
dualistica è vecchia e precostituita non
è vera cioè semplicistica e non è vera
io ho pensato che ci potesse essere una
terza via
ho pensato che ci potesse essere una
terza via e capivo che mi prendessero
per folle quelle quelle otto persone
allora ho pensato che per vedere le cose
che vedevo io allora dovevo fargliele
vedere
e dovevo partire da quello che avevo
che cosa avevo avevo questo peperone
questo scillone si chiama così
atteggiano la cui cultura si stava
perdendo però era lì ed era tipica di
teggiano aveva una capacità
straordinaria delle persone del posto di
saperlo trasformare artigianalmente
perché questo essiccato poi va
trasformato avevo quella formazione che
i miei genitori mi avevano aiutato ad
avere la mia famiglia aveva sostenuto ad
avere come quella dei miei dei miei
colleghi e poi avevo un concetto molto
antico ma molto moderno che era nato a
pochi chilometri da casa mia in magna
grecia kalòs e agathos il bello e il
buono ma il bello e buono non come
concetti estetici e di gusto il bello e
buono come concetti anche etici e morali
e allora ho pensato che potevo prendere
questo concetto di bello e di buono
potevo utilizzare il bello per custodire
il buono e fare in modo che quella
formazione che i miei genitori mi
avessero dato mi permettesse di
uscire cioè di unire questi due mondi
quello agricolo e quello artigianale
crearne uno completamente nuovo quello
agro artigianale facendo un progetto che
potesse
invertire quella spirale
creando ricchezza sul posto creando
ricchezza sul territorio lasciando
quella ricchezza sul territorio e magari
incrementarla e questo ho fatto dal 2017
cercando di metterlo in quella bustina
perché quella bustina contiene qualcosa
che sicuramente serve ad un'azienda per
stare in piedi
dobbiamo vivere dobbiamo campare ma
contiene anche cose che non si vedono
voi vedete quella bustina
ma quello che non si vede in quella
bustina e che lì dentro c'è un sistema
di coltivazione che abbiamo creato che
permette di includere
10 coltivatori atteggiano senza fargli
fare grandi investimenti ma che ci
permette di custodire la coltivazione
del peperone dentro quella bustina c'è
un sistema di essiccazione e lavorazione
a mano di questo peperone queste
antonietta la amo che ci permette di
preservare il lavoro prezioso che fa
antonietta e e di metterlo lì dentro
ma insieme a queste due cose quindi la
terra e l'artigianato c'è anche un
sistema di marketing di tracciabilità
digitale e di marketing e di vendita che
ci permette di distribuire in tutto il
mondo e fare in modo di prendere il
reddito da fuori e portarlo all'interno
della piccola comunità di teggiano in
modo tale che forse nel nostro piccolo
possiamo essere l'esempio per bloccare
quella forbice che si allarga quella
quel divario fra le due spirali e creare
un'occasione economica vera che resti su
un territorio e che sia un'occasione su
un territorio che cosa è successo in
questi cinque anni nel 2017
ero da solo
adesso siamo in dieci l'avete visto
non c'era un sistema di coltivazione
adesso c'è un sistema di coltivazione e
un disciplinare di produzione il
peperone tutelato e poi in azienda
ero da solo adesso siamo in sei ne manca
uno qui manca davide siamo in sei e
siamo destinati a crescere allora quello
che ho capito in questo percorso di sei
anni e che c'era bisogno di far vedere
alle persone che fosse possibile
c'era bisogno di mostrargli le cose che
non vedevano perchè io forse sul
peperone sotto e giano vedevo cose che
gli altri non vedevano e se adesso voi
prendete quella bustina la aprite e
assaporate quel peperone vi renderete
conto forse che per me
atteggiano sud italia mediterraneo il
futuro e croccante
[Applauso]